Here's something strange. You can spot
talent in others instantly, but when it
comes to your own abilities, suddenly
you're blind. Your brain has 86 billion
neurons, creating connections that have
never existed before in the universe.
Yet, you probably thought about yourself
negatively today. Right now, your brain
is processing 11 million bits of
information per second, but you're only
consciously aware of maybe 40. Let me
blow your mind. You have implicit memory
storing every skill you've ever learned.
All running automatically like apps you
forgot were open. And here's the kicker.
That imposttor syndrome you feel. Plot
twist. It's actually evidence of
intelligence. Only smart people can
doubt themselves that sophisticatedly.
Your biggest talents are invisible to
you because they don't feel like
talents. They feel like just how you
think. Tonight, ask yourself, "What
problem did I solve today?" Because once
you start looking for brilliance, you
realize it was never hiding.